für amerikas abtreibungsgegner ist er
eine galionsfigur mark dixon 36 jahre
texaner
abtreibungen sind für ihn teufelszeug
mit seinen predigten tot er durchs land
und kämpft für einen radikalen wandel in
amerikas sexualpolitik
abtreibung schadet frauen es ist etwas
das wir aus unserer kultur verbannen
sollten meiner meinung nach ist der
kampf gegen abtreibung nicht anders als
der kampf gegen die sklaverei früher
oder der kampf gegen selbstmord heute
mag ist einer der anführer eines lange
vorbereiteten republikanischen kurs seit
jahren organisiert er beispielsweise
unterschriften petitionen um gesetze auf
lokaler ebene abtreibungs feindlicher zu
machen
mit spannung blickt er auf das
anstehende supreme court urteil er hofft
dass möglichst viele republikanische
bundesstaaten schwangerschafts abbrüche
verbieten werden sobald sie selbst
darüber entscheiden dürfen selbst bei
vergewaltigungen will er keine ausnahmen
[Musik]
abtreibungen in texas ganz verboten
werden dann denke ich werden manche
leute entscheiden dass sie lieber
woanders leben möchte wenn manche
menschen hier in amerika also die
gesetze in ihren bundesstaaten nicht
mögen sollen sie halt woanders hinziehen
der jahrzehntealte streit um
abtreibungen ist neu entfacht nachdem
ein urteilsentwurf des supreme court
öffentlich wurde der text des
konservativen richter samuel alito liest
sich wie ein manifest radikale
abtreibungsgegner
so sei das bis heute maßgebliche urteil
von 1973 von beginn an ungeheuerlich
falsch gewesen die bundesregelung durch
keine verfassungsrechtliche vorschrift
gedeckt deshalb sei es jetzt zeit die
abtreibungsfrage den gewählten
vertretern des volkes zurückzugeben
einer abtreibungsklinik in houston texas
es ist einer der schwierigsten tage in
fischers leben die alleinerziehende
dreifache mutter ist in der fünften
woche schwanger trotz verhütung
ich habe es meinen job aber da sind die
steigenden benzinpreise versicherungen
teurer werdende lebensmittels
kinderbetreuungskosten wissen sie ich
kann uns jetzt schon gerade so über
wasser halten ich kann das moment
unmöglich schaffen nur noch ein kind zu
versorgen
hätte völlig ja die schwangerschaft
später bemerkt hätte sie für den
eingriff in einen anderen staat fahren
müssen in texas sind abtreibungen noch
bis zur sechsten woche möglich bald
könnten sie ganz verboten sein die leute
da oben die entscheidungen für uns
treffen verdienen 100.000 200.000 dollar
oder mehr im jahr sie haben also eine
möglichkeit wir sind hart arbeitende
leute die es gerade so von monat zu
monat schaffen diese leute sehen das
nicht aus unserer perspektive und sie
hören uns auch nicht zu sie haben
unseren schmerz und unsere probleme
nicht auf dem radar wenn sie solche
entscheidungen treffen
wenige autostunden entfernt in aargau
texas treffen wir auch in schladming man
könnte die evangelikale als so etwas wie
eine gemäßigte konstruktive
abtreibungsgegnerin bezeichnen um jungen
müttern zu helfen die nicht abtreiben
können oder wollen hat sie eine
initiative gegründet mit spendengeldern
stellt sie übergangsweise fünf
alleinstehenden schwangeren wohnungen
zur verfügung bietet gesprächsrunden an
finanziert weiterbildungen
das projekt kommt so gut an dass aubry
expandieren will auf diesem gelände soll
eine ranch entstehen für 20 schwangere
die jeweils etwa ein jahr lang
kostenfrei hier wohnen sollen in obhut
sollen die familien lernen künftig
allein und ohne finanzielle hilfe
klarzukommen für ihre vision sammelt sie
gemeinsam mit ihrer kirche spenden und
sucht investoren
wie wollen sie meine platz für ihre
familie geben sie sind also immer noch
für ihre kinder verantwortlich aber
haben ein sicheres umfeld in dem ihre
kinder problemlos herumrennen oder mit
den anderen familien spielen können und
unser team soll sie beraten und bei
vielen dingen unterstützen so dass sie
ihr leben wieder auf die reihe bekommen
und unabhängig sein
für eine der mütter veranstaltete heute
eine baby-party whitney hat bald ihren
entbindungstermin die dreifache mutter
wurde von ihrem ex mann jahrelang
misshandelt als sie erfuhr dass sie
wieder schwanger ist hatte sie angst
dass er sie umbringen
unter dem slogan einfach abgehauen und
ich hatte im moment nicht die kraft
meine kinder mitzunehmen haben
und das lässt mich nicht mehr los selbst
während ich hier sitze kann ich nicht
aufhören daran zu denken
es merkt vielleicht keiner weil ich
immer versuche stark zu sein das ist
etwas das keine mutter jemals durch
machen sollte
whitney wollte zunächst abtreiben dann
traf sie ok die sie in ihr programm
aufgenommen sie half ihr dabei ihre
kinder zu ihr zu holen und sich von
ihrem ex mann zu trennen am ende
entschied sich britney ihr ungeborenes
kind zu behalten
ich denke für eine frau es ist das beste
wenn man ihr die möglichkeit gibt selbst
zu entscheiden denn es gibt nicht sehr
viele solche initiativen
ich habe einfach großes glück gehabt es
gibt zwar durchaus argumente für ein
abtreibungsverbot
aber am ende könnte auch dass frauen in
eine ganz furchtbare situation bringen
so differenziert sehen es wohl nicht
viele amerikaner nur wenige menschen die
versuchen brücken zu bauen während die
gesellschaftlichen gräben in amerika
weiter aufreißen und das land vor einem
fundamentalen wandel in der
abtreibungspolitik steht